Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
[Stéphanie Raphaël, artiste digitale]
(Musique : « Lucky you »
par Alice on the roof)
[présente les Miss Notes]
(La musique se termine)
Bonjour.
(Applaudissements)
Vous venez de découvrir les Miss Notes.
Les Miss Notes
sont le fruit de ma créativité.
Je suis artiste digitale,
touchscreen artist.
Je crée avec mon doigt,
directement sur l’écran de mon iPhone,
sans aucune autre
application que les Notes,
et je crée des portraits de femmes.
Tout a commencé un soir de janvier 2016,
je venais de rendre mon atelier, voilà,
un bel atelier où je peignais avec
des pastels, des pigments, des pinceaux,
sur de grandes toiles en lin,
mais voilà : plus d’endroit pour peindre.
Et au même moment,
je décide d’acquérir le dernier iPhone.
Le soir, je rentre chez moi,
impossible de trouver le sommeil.
Une heure, deux heures,
trois heures du matin,
toujours les yeux ouverts.
Alors... je plonge
mon bras dans l’obscurité,
j’approche mon iPhone, et je me dis:
«Tiens, quelles sont
les dernières fonctionnalités
de ma dernière acquisition?»
Alors, je regarde, je cherche.
J’ouvre les Notes, et je me dis :
«Qu’ont-elles de nouveau ces Notes?»
Là, je clique,
surgissent trois crayons,
une gomme, une règle, quelques couleurs.
Instinctivement,
je pose mon doigt sur l’écran,
et je commence à créer ce qui sera,
sans le savoir,
ma toute première Miss Notes.
Alors, pourquoi « Miss Notes »?
« Miss » parce que ce sont des femmes,
« Notes » parce que je les réalise
dans l’application Notes.
Vous connaissez cette application?
On peut prendre, comme son nom
l’indique, des notes.
On y inscrit quelques mots.
Je réalise une Miss Notes,
puis deux, trois.
Je les poste sur les réseaux sociaux.
Ça fait le buzz.
Et là, je développe
une série de e-portraits
de femmes digitales,
innovantes, les Notes,
multiethniques,
le regard frontal, l’air affirmé.
À votre avis,
d’où vient la créativité?
Qu’est-ce qui vous, vous pousse à créer ?
Quelle a été votre dernière création ?
La forme qu’elle a prise,
d’où elle est venue ?
En ce qui me concerne,
la créativité, ce soir-là,
a pris la forme, je dois le dire,
d’un véritable coup de foudre,
une rencontre presque fusionnelle
avec l’écran de cet iPhone.
D’abord son toucher,
c'est frais, lisse, délicat,
et puis,
le tapotement des doigts
sur l’écran comme une musique,
et cette palette quand même
extrêmement réduite
qui vous pousse à vous réinventer.
La créativité prend donc
naissance dans la curiosité!
Souvenez-vous: «Tiens,
qu’ont-elles de nouveau ces Notes?»
Oui, c’est bien le fait d’explorer.
Et paradoxalement,
cette créativité prend aussi naissance
dans le lâcher prise.
Laisser venir à soi l’instant présent,
c'est vrai.
Si vous travaillez la matière,
la matière vous répond.
Elle vous fait créateur.
La créativité est donc bien ce paradoxe
qui s’auto-nourrit entre
« aller vers » par la curiosité,
et « laisser venir à soi »
par le lâcher prise,
ce qui permet, donc,
aux Miss Notes, de se révéler.
C’est l’Ar(t)révélation.
Et cette créativité
est un processus infini,
permanent, qui se propage.
Une Miss Notes amène
une deuxième Miss Notes, puis trois,
trente, quarante,
quatre-vingts Miss Notes.
Aujourd’hui, les Miss Notes
sont rétroprojetées
sur les monuments nationaux,
devant la Pyramide du Louvre,
sur l’Arc de Triomphe.
On peut les voir dans les musées:
au Tate, à Londres, à côté d’un Bonnard,
et puis lors de nuits blanches,
sur des façades numériques.
Pourquoi pas vous?
Oui, vous aussi,
laissez-vous surprendre
par cet effet de propagation,
parce que tout le monde ici peut créer
quel que soit votre domaine,
du domaine artistique qui est le mien,
jusqu’au domaine scientifique.
Avant d’être artiste-peintre,
j’étais comédienne.
J’ai eu la chance de jouer
au théâtre, j’ai tourné.
J'ai même été animatrice, j’ai chanté.
Eh bien, que ce soit la rencontre
avec les Notes de l’iPhone,
ou la rencontre avec un personnage,
le processus créatif
qui mène à la révélation
est identique.
D’abord, vous faites
l’expérience de la matière.
Vous cumulez de la connaissance :
pour l’artiste-peintre,
les formes, les couleurs ;
et puis, pour la comédienne:
la respiration,
la voix,
(En criant) le volume,
(En murmurant) le volume,
le débit,
(En parlant vite) accéléré,
(En parlant lentement) ralenti,
la gestuelle,
le corps dans l’espace.
Une fois que vous avez
aiguisé votre instrument,
eh bien comme le peintre avec sa palette,
vous faites preuve de curiosité
avec le texte de l’auteur.
On se fait plaisir, citons
Shakespeare, Roméo et Juliette:
«Galopez prestement,
coursiers aux pieds de feu.»
C'est magnifique.
Alors là, on explore, on cherche.
On travaille le texte dans
tous les sens, on expérimente.
Alors, Juliette... galopez
prestement, coursiers aux pieds de feu.
Juliette est amoureuse, lui aussi,
mais les familles ne sont pas d'accord.
Ce n'est pas possible,
donc c'est grave, c’est dramatique...
(En déclamant) Galopez prestement,
coursiers aux pieds de feu !
Non, ce n'est pas du tout Juliette ;
elle est beaucoup
plus fraîche, plus jeune,
Oui, c'est ça, plus volatile !
(Avec exaltation) Galopez prestement,
coursiers aux pieds de feu.
Oui, elle prie, elle supplie.
Voilà, on cherche, on expérimente,
et puis, à un moment donné,
on lâche prise.
Et là,
le personnage vient à vous.
Il s’incarne à travers vous.
« Galopez prestement,
coursiers aux pieds de feu. »
C’est l’Art-révélation...
... encore.
Et vous alors,
qu’est-ce qui se révèle à vous?
J’étais peintre, j’étais comédienne
et puis un matin,
je me rends sur un tournage,
et là, tout à fait par hasard,
je croise une amie.
Elle me dit:
«Stéphanie, tu ne donnerais pas
des cours de théâtre ?
C'est pour ma fille.
- Jusqu’ici, j’ai surtout joué la comédie,
mais écoute, pourquoi pas ?
Je veux bien essayer!»
J’ouvre un cours de théâtre.
Première année, expérimentale,
j’accueille des passionnés de théâtre,
et puis, j’ai quelques timides,
des anxieux aussi.
Et l’année suivante,
j’ouvre un cours de préparation mentale
pour les auditions, les castings,
pour avoir une meilleure gestion
du stress en situation de concours.
Et là, une nouvelle
matière s’offre à moi:
les timides, le théâtre,
la gestion du mental.
Alors, comme dans un petit laboratoire,
je commence à faire mes expériences,
«Plus fort… moins vite,
ah, on va travailler le mental.»
Et là, je m’aperçois
qu’avec une meilleure connaissance
physiologique et mentale,
le timide pouvait faire preuve
de curiosité avec le monde qui l’entoure,
tout en lâchant prise
par rapport au regard des autres,
ce qui lui permettait de se révéler,
de révéler sa personnalité,
et donc gagner en affirmation.
De la créativité digitale,
je passais à la créativité théâtrale,
mais appliquée à l’humain.
Ouah !
La créativité comme levier,
levier de confiance, d'affirmation.
Ah !
Vous vous souvenez,
par effet de propagation -
une chose qui en amène une autre -
je commence à construire, à imaginer
des exercices qui deviennent des outils.
Et sans m'en rendre compte, finalement,
je commence à créer une méthode.
Et un soir, je jouais au théâtre,
et dans la salle,
un directeur de cabinet d'une entreprise
aéronautique vient me voir.
Il avait vu le spectacle, et il me
retrouve à la sortie des artistes.
Il m'interpelle : «Madame Raphaël,
je trouve que vous avez une bonne diction,
est-ce que vous pouvez faire
quelque chose pour notre dirigeant.
Il parle vite et il voudrait
gagner en impact. »
Moi : « Jusqu’ici je n’ai accompagné
que des particuliers,
mais écoutez, pourquoi pas ?
Je veux bien essayer!»
Et aujourd'hui, la méthode inédite
qui venait d'être créée,
recommandée
aujourd'hui par les scientifiques,
a aidé plus de 2 500 personnes,
dans les hôpitaux,
les centres de recherche,
les entreprises et les universités,
à se révéler.
Avec des outils adaptés,
issus de méthodes créatives,
on pouvait ouvrir de très grandes portes.
Je me souviens d’Aymeric.
Aymeric, je l’ai rencontré à l’INRIA,
un centre de recherche dans le numérique.
Aymeric est doctorant.
Il allait bientôt soutenir sa thèse,
et il était terrorisé à l’idée
de prendre la parole en public.
Pour lui, c’était un véritable handicap.
Aymeric, c'est le seul
participant que j'ai eu
qui s'était assis de profil
et quand son regard croisait
mon regard, il tournait la tête.
C'était...
émouvant !
Aymeric au sein d'un groupe,
lorsque je demandais
à tous de lever les bras -
je vous montre le maximum d'Aymeric:
donc là, on était au maximum,
tellement, le pauvre,
il se sentait ridicule,
il n'osait même pas lever les bras.
Au sein de son laboratoire,
personne ne connaissait le son de sa voix.
Il rasait les murs.
Eh bien, Aymeric a investi
du travail personnel.
Il a appris à respirer.
Il a posé le discours sur la respiration.
Il a donné des gestes.
Sa voix a commencé à sortir.
De l'intérieur, elle est sortie.
Et puis il a récupéré de la confiance.
Et je le raconte parce que
l'histoire est belle :
Aymeric a soutenu sa thèse
avec les félicitations du jury
pour son aisance à l'oral.
C'est une belle histoire.
Et d'ailleurs Aymeric, je lui ai envoyé
un texto il y a deux jours.
Je lui ai dit : « Je vais parler de toi,
j'ai la chance d'être invitée au TED. »
Je vais vous montrer la réponse,
parce qu'elle est jolie aussi.
Je lui ai demandé comment
se passaient ses prises de parole.
Il m'a répondu : « Je viens de faire
une présentation à un congrès.
Tous m'ont dit que je me débrouillais bien
à l'oral, ça m'a fait super plaisir ! »
C'est vrai qu'avec des petites
portes, avec de vrais outils,
on peut vraiment ouvrir
le champ des possibles.
Claire !
Claire est manageuse
dans une grande entreprise.
Alors Claire avait un double défi :
elle devait animer des réunions
et faire des présentations.
Claire manquait
tellement de confiance en elle
pendant ses réunions,
qu'elle prétextait
avoir oublié un dossier,
et fonçait aux toilettes.
On la retrouvait par terre
à s'asperger d'eau.
Claire, la toute première fois
que je l'ai rencontrée,
elle ne pouvait pas prononcer
le mot « présentation ».
Elle fondait en larmes.
Je vous raconte
le premier entretien avec elle.
Elle est venue me voir :
« Bonjour madame Raphael, voilà,
dans une semaine donc
j'ai une (sanglotant) présentation. »
C'était la première phrase de Claire.
J'ai dit : « On va prendre le temps.
Alors, racontez-moi, Claire, donc,
le sujet de votre présentation.
- Madame Raphaël, donc, oui, bien sûr,
alors, le sujet (sanglotant)
de la présentation... »
Voilà.
Une heure, on n'a pas dépassé
cette phrase avec ce mot-là.
Puis, elle est revenue
me voir, on a travaillé.
Elle a appris à mieux s'occuper d'elle.
Elle a désinvesti le regard des autres.
Petit à petit,
elle a récupéré en confiance,
elle a gagné surtout en concentration.
Aujourd'hui, Claire a une promotion.
Et je ne résiste pas
à vous parler de Jérémy.
Jérémy, je l'ai rencontré
à l'école de la nouvelle chance,
phobique social.
Donc Jérémy a été
déscolarisé, rescolarisé...
L'année dernière, il devait passer
son bac de français, l'oral blanc.
Il n'a pas pu se présenter,
il a passé trois heures
à pleurer dans le bureau de la directrice.
Premier cours avec Jérémy, aucun son.
Au sein de sa classe,
personne n'entendait un mot -
en tout cas en groupe - de Jérémy.
Et pareil, on a fait des exercices,
d'abord physiques,
et petit à petit,
voilà, on a entendu un mot,
puis deux,
puis après on a récupéré
en résistance, on a surchargé.
La sensibilité qu'il avait,
on l'a canalisée.
Donc double victoire pour Jérémy :
il a réussi à se présenter
à l'oral - c'était déjà formidable -
et il a eu 14.
Les exemples paraissent extrêmes :
timide pathologique, dirigeant,
mais eux, c'est nous.
Et tout le monde peut progresser à l'oral
avec des techniques basées, entre autres,
sur les techniques d'acteur
et une bonne gestion du mental.
Pour tous, c'est possible.
(Soupir)
J'étais quand même loin
de me douter, finalement,
de tout ce que la créativité
allait me permettre de réaliser.
Elle m'a permis de soutenir,
d'aider les gens à mieux se connaitre.
Et toutes ces femmes digitales,
ces Miss notes finalement,
elles m'ont poussée à quoi ?
Elles m'ont poussée à m'engager,
elles m'ont rendue plus généreuse.
Pour ces femmes,
j'ai donc mis au point des outils
pour qu'elles puissent
être plus assertives,
développer de l'autorité
naturelle, dans la détente,
à la fois dans leur domaine
professionnel mais également personnel.
Ces Miss Notes qui m'ont
rendue plus généreuse,
aujourd'hui, elles soutiennent
l'Institut Gustave Roussy.
C'est-à-dire que, simplement,
pour chaque Miss Notes
que vous souhaitez acquérir,
une Miss Notes est offerte à l'Institut,
dont les bénéfices
vont soutenir la recherche.
Et puisque les Miss Notes sont une grande
chaîne de femmes, une chaîne sororelle,
j'ai le plaisir de mettre en lumière
mes ambassadrices qui sont :
Assia Benziane - si vous la voyez
apparaître en haut à gauche.
Assia est formidable.
Elle est membre du G7,
et œuvre au quotidien
pour la parité homme-femme.
Toute jeune, à 18 ans,
elle a créé des écoles en Afrique
pour l'éducation des petites filles.
À côté d'Assia, se trouve Eléanor Sohier.
Pilote à seulement 17 ans,
elle représente aujourd'hui
l'aviation légère française.
Vous avez en-dessous d'Assia,
Nathalie Lebas-Vautier,
formidable, une femme de cœur, d'action.
Nathalie est fondatrice d'Ekyog,
une marque de mode,
une des toutes premières éco-responsables,
une pionnière.
Et puis Christelle Chollet,
douée et merveilleuse
actrice de music-hall,
douée pour le rire,
douée pour l'humour et directrice
du théâtre de la Tour Eiffel.
Et parce que les Miss Notes
continuent à se réinventer,
eh bien, je me suis mise en cuisine.
J'ai concocté un colinot
au chorizo, que vous voyez là,
que j'ai transformé en Miss Food.
On se réinvente, et entre deux recettes,
il m'arrive de prendre
en photo mes baskets
que je transforme en Miss Street.
La créativité vous apprend sur vous.
La créativité vous révèle.
Et la créativité est partout.
Moi, c'est vrai, tout m'inspire :
un son,
une couleur, le silence,
une voix...
Mais tout le monde peut créer,
quel que soit son domaine.
Que tu sois musicien, danseuse,
bricolo, artiste,
devant ta page blanche,
derrière tes fourneaux, ton microscope,
allez demain, chantons sous la douche,
codons, osons, expérimentons,
créons !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)